[Music]
no one knows exactly when humans started
traveling venturing beyond the little
corner of the world they knew to
discover new places
in some ways
it feels like it's always been part of
who we are as a species
before babies can even walk or talk
they're trying to climb out of their
cribs to explore
it's something that we need
to see what's out there
for some of us that means what's across
the street or in the next town for
others it's what's in the next continent
at national geographic we meet lots of
explorers who've been to lots of places
people who have a serious travel bug
but i've never met a more dedicated more
curious traveler than jessica nabongo so
i was in bali i was in rome i was in
miami in afghanistan we walked across
the bridge from uzbekistan my friend was
doing peace corps in fiji so i went to
see her this australian guy at
mcdonald's and osaka so i went to
australia and i saw him i went on a solo
my first solo trip ever to costa rica so
when i was in kyrgyzstan with a friend
of mine i was like oh my god i'm so
excited to sleep in a year when i was in
mongolia i stayed in a gur
which is the same thing as a year but at
mongolia they call it a girl that was
like seven days
and i went from indonesia
to la through sydney to detroit
to senegal you know like it was
so painful
i'm peter guinn editor-at-large at
national geographic and you're listening
to overheard a show where we eavesdrop
on the wild conversations we have here
at natgeo and follow them to the edges
of our big weird beautiful world this
week we talked to jessica nabongo the
first black woman known to have traveled
to all 195 u.n recognized nations we'll
hear about some of her adventures which
by the way she wrote about in her new
book the catch me if you can one woman's
journey to every country in the world
and we'll also ask her about what she's
learned along the way
more after the break
but before that if you like what you
hear please consider a national
geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overheard and to ensure
that we keep providing you with stories
from the edges of our big weird
beautiful world go to natgeo.com forward
slash explore to subscribe
back in a minute
there's this whole community of country
counters you know a bunch of weirdos
like me and i'm like oh my god
accurately tracking exactly how many
people have traveled to every country in
the world is super difficult there's not
an official body that tracks this
but by many counts the numbers less than
200. out of over 7 billion 150 they're
like more people have been to outer
space than have been every country in
the world
we checked with nasa and that's actually
true
in 2021 the 600th person went to space
yet even with modern transportation
going to every country down on the
planet is still guinness world records
territory
people embark on this sort of epic
travel for many different reasons
bottomless curiosity the thrill of the
chase a desire to rack up a ridiculous
number of frequent fire miles
but jessica was sort of born into the
life of a traveler she grew up with
basically one foot on two different
continents her parents had immigrated to
the u.s from uganda
and those early family trips back to
africa helped make her feel at home with
vastly different ways of life
and planted the seas for her future
travels
i think
because
i was so young when i first went to
uganda and it wasn't made out to be like
a foreign place it was just like okay
we're going home um and you know i met
my cousins i met like my grandmother
my mom is from a village with no running
water and electricity and there was
never this value judgment and i really
appreciated that because i think that
also shapes how i look at the world
nowadays it's not good or bad it's just
it's different
as jessica grew older she started to
wonder
what could i find in all these other
places around the world
i think what i used to do was like spin
the globe and then pick a place and then
i would look in the encyclopedia
and just see what was what
but she followed the tried and true life
path she went to college in new york
city and then started her career in her
hometown of detroit
and then she did something that many
people thought was crazy she quit her
job and sort of on a whim moved to japan
i resigned i shaved my head because i
was like
i'm not going to find anyone to do my
black hair in japan
she spent a year in japan teaching
english and then moved to london for
grad school next she took a job in rome
for three years and then spent six
months in benin before eventually moving
back to the u.s
but all during this time she was
traveling to other countries in europe
asia and africa and so it was actually
during that time that i started my blog
to catch me if you can because my
friends would always like call me carmen
san diego and they're like where's
jessica now
by 2017 she'd racked up 60 countries and
had a devoted following of readers
and then during a trip to bali she had
an epiphany you know finally like
spiritual awakenings occur and when i
was there i heard or i read about an
american woman named cassie de picole
who had just gotten the guinness record
for doing it the fastest
it was like 18 and a half months she did
193 countries in 18 and a half months i
having been to every country in the
world that still blows my mind the pure
exhaustion of it all
seriously
not only did cassie depecal get the
guinness world record for the fastest
time to visit all sovereign nations
she was also the first woman known ever
to do it it took the peckle exactly one
year and 194 days to make it to every
country but a couple years later another
american woman named taylor de monbrine
beat de peckle's record with a time of
one year 189 days so then i was like
have any black person done this and i
found out about this guy named slawek
maturi
he's half kenyan half polish
and i met him finally this past august i
met him in warsaw he's been to every
country twice and he's like 50 countries
away from doing it three times i'm like
you're insane i'm not doing that
wow but
but yeah so once i did all that i found
out no black woman had done it and so
i decided
then that i wanted to be the first black
woman to visit every country in the
world
while jessica wasn't interested in
beating world records for the fastest
time she did set herself a deadline make
it to the remaining 135 countries by her
35th birthday which is two and a half
years away but her project wasn't just
about ticking destinations off a list
it was deeper than that i wanted to have
a cultural experience in every country i
visited
like
i wanted to know why this country
is unique
okay
good morning
we're still in mount crystal
we're about to go for this hike
uh to the grand cascade which is the big
waterfall
let's do it
jessica nabanga has had enough
adventures of a lifetime to fill well
lots of lifetimes
editing this episode was difficult
because she told us so many great
stories it was hard to choose from there
was the time when she went to tonga
and swam with hunk pack whales you know
i'm a pretty good swimmer i did i wasn't
certified for scuba so i snorkeled and i
was so scared because it's a humpback
whale so first of all it's bigger than
the boat we're in so i'm like how do you
know it's not gonna hit the boat and
we're gonna all flip over and die here
and so you know i get in but i'm like
super nervous
and then i really like get into it and
it's incredible and they sort of are
playing with you so they're watching you
when they're like doing flips in south
sudan she visited a cattle camp endinka
culture like cattle is incredibly
important so we spent like three hours
in a cattle camp you know milking cows
and just hanging out but it wasn't all
smooth sailing take for example her dog
sledding experience above the arctic
circle in norway these girls behind us
weren't paying attention their sled
slams into me
so the dogs knocked me but then the the
sled which came after the dog slammed
into me
what i didn't realize until a month
later was that i actually tore my labrum
which is kind of what connects to your
leg and your hip i guess
my doctor was like what happened i was
like well i was in a dog sledding
accident in norway
but some of her most precious gems
the little beautiful moments of
revelation caught her completely by
surprise
like once in dakar the capital of
senegal she stopped at a beach to check
out the local surf scene
here she is reading from her blog post
portraits of senegal
my first full day in the car my host had
to work and i was left to wander around
we had lunch across the street from a
surf shop so i wanted over
i noticed paca in the distance as he
came out of the water i watched him walk
towards me passing over the rocks
yelling at a small girl and showering
before he headed back to the surf shop
i was struck by his dark skin and the
displaced surfboard under his arm i had
never seen a black surfer let alone an
african one
in the first use of my french here in
senegal i first asked the owner of the
shop if i could take pictures then him
if i could take his picture
he thought i wanted a picture of me with
the board when i corrected him he seemed
delighted
in some places the experience was all
about the food for example
one of the best places for food is the
country of georgia they have these
dumplings that are filled filled with
meat
they make um
this really delicious flatbread and it's
also the birthplace of wine so we went
to vineyards and we went to all these
wine bars and learned so much about the
history of wine but sometimes you get
served something that you're not really
sure what it is but hey eating is an
important part of the adventure of
traveling and learning about a different
culture
last week while traveling in gabon we
sat down for lunch i ordered veggies and
rice and sal ordered chicken once our
dishes were served another dish was
brought to the table
neither of us knew what it was but it
was presented as a local dish i made a
video of sal eating it and we were later
told it was pangolin an animal i had
never heard of it was in french so i
assumed the name was different in
english in fact i called it an armadillo
when i saw a picture uh yeah pangolins
do kind of look like armadillos but
according to the world wildlife fund
they are also the most trafficked mammal
in the world
in certain countries pangolins are used
in traditional medicine as well as
consumed as a delicacy
and as a result the eight species of
pangolin range in status from vulnerable
to critically endangered
as you can imagine once i learned of
this i was shocked and removed the video
from my page
i in no way want to contribute to the
extinction of any vulnerable or
endangered animals there are three types
of penguin in gabon the giant pangolin
has been legally protected since 1987
however this is not the case with the
other two species of pongolim which are
often hunted for bushmeat this
information was taken from eyes on
environment i encourage you to do more
research on this animal to learn more
about conservation efforts and ways that
you can support these efforts
more after the break
though traveling was mostly fun
jessica had her share of rough moments
in paris someone tried to steal her
phone and in rome a cab driver tried to
kiss her
but the worst was a moment in pakistan
she'd had a great time visiting the
country but when she arrived at the
airport in lahore to depart
the security guards dug through her
luggage doubted the validity of her
american passport and aggressively
questioned her about where she was going
and why then they put me into an x-ray
not a metal detector a medical x-ray and
when i'm like what is going on they're
like oh sometimes people keep the drugs
in their stomach so i'm like
okay so now i'm freaking out i'm like oh
you think i'm a drunk meal got it okay
so once they find out that i'm in fact
not carrying drugs in my stomach they
let me go check in so i check in they're
being rude to me at the check-in i'm
like okay i'm trying to keep it together
and then i go to security
and in muslim countries
women go into like a private little box
for the security
i go in and the woman has me spread my
legs it was literally
that is the worst thing that has
happened to me in the last decade i mean
really in all of my travels because it
was i felt so violated i'd never
experienced anything like that i was
alone i'm like crying
and it was
it was just awful
and here's where i want to talk about
the importance
and how we tell stories
when bad things happen to us
i recognize the reason that happened to
me is because
there's apparently a large drug
trafficking triangle between pakistan
and west africa right so it's
specifically because i'm visibly african
i had such an amazing time in pakistan
it's you know conservative muslim
country i was mostly with men the entire
time i was there had an amazing time
everyone was so nice to me
um strangers it was it was
phenomenal and so for me
i have most issues with immigration when
i travel because people think my us
password is fake because apparently
africans can't be americans weird and
then um if i have my event and passport
they think i'm gonna like overstay a
visa
i'm able to separate the horrible
experiences that i have with immigration
from my experience of the country
and i think for me
in particular but i think everyone
that's really important because we can't
equate
governments
with people
those exist on two different planes like
we can't equate politics with visiting a
country
in 2019 with about 40 countries left
jessica thought about giving up
the constant travel was physically
draining and what was supposed to be a
fun mission was turning into a slog when
i was in mali
which i think was country 154 i was
again burnt out
and
over it i remember facetiming my friend
ashley and i was like what am i doing
like this is dumb i can't i can't do
this anymore like i'm exhausted i'm
going broke like this is just not a good
idea and i remember i met this
photographer and we went to we went to
the market and we're in the market and
he's telling them like what i'm doing
and they're like what like say pathway
it's not true um saying posible is
impossible and i'm like yeah now that's
what i'm doing blah blah
and then one of them said
pornu it's not for you it's for us
and that was a turning point for jessica
she'd started this journey with the goal
of seeing how people live in every
country in the world but she realized
that because she was sharing her travels
on her blog and social media
other people were making these trips
with her
and so when i talk about how
the journey became so much bigger than
me is because other people began to have
a stake in what it meant for me as a
black woman to be traveling to every
country in the world and it really was
them and molly who
who gave me that push they really gave
me the push that i needed
to
to finish that journey
finally in october 2019 a few months
after her 35th birthday jessica made it
to the last country on her list the last
country was the seychelles
i wanted a place in africa so that was
important to me because i love
the african continent so much um it's
definitely my favorite region in the
world and and i wanted a place that my
friends were gonna come so in the end
there were 55 people there celebrating
with me like friends and family in the
seychelles jessica threw a dinner party
with a dj
in fact her friends and family joked
that it was her wedding the government
of the seychelles were very kind they um
they gave me a coco de mer which is the
largest plant or the largest seed in the
plant kingdom wow yeah it's really
it's interesting you have to google a
picture of it but it looks like
the bottom half of a woman uh and it's
it's very
it's very unique to the seychelles and
so they gave me one that sits on my
bookshelf
these days it may seem like the world is
shrunk
google earth lets us look at any spot on
the globe in seconds
people jump on planes every day jetting
off to practically every corner of the
planet
and we're inundated with world news 24
7. but the truth is
the earth is vast and jessica nabongo
has been all over it making connections
with people all along the way
so the big question is
what has she learned that's such a good
question oh
this is where the heavy music is going
to play right here
the dramatic music
you know
my tip now if you want to travel to
places like this
is you have a local guide you have that
local connection someone who knows more
than you someone who knows more than
foreign journalists someone who's living
there every single day
but there's also a lesson about human
nature that she picked up truly for me
it's the kindness of strangers
that
made my journey what it was i'm like
getting emotional um because i can't all
of my amazing stories have people in
them
it's not like oh i hiked this mountain
and it was so incredible i mean that's
great too
but to me so much of experiencing the
world is experiencing it with people
right you there's mountains everywhere
what makes the mountain different you
know what i mean but the way we can
understand the world and love the world
and
love humanity
is by meeting people and becoming quick
friends
[Music]
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and please consider a national
geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overheard
go to natgeo.com forward slash explore
to subscribe
and if you want to learn more about
jessica's travels her book the catch me
if you can one woman's journey to every
country in the world comes out in june
it includes lots of her photographs from
around the world you can also check out
her blog post at thecatchmeifucan.com
or follow her on instagram at jessica
nabongo that's all in the show notes
they're right there in your podcast app
[Music]
this week's overheard episode is
produced by kyrie douglas our producers
are alana strauss and marcy thompson
our senior producers are brian gutierrez
and jacob pinter
our senior editor is eli chen
our manager of audio's carla wills
our executive producer of audio is devar
ardulon who edited this episode
our fact checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer our photo editor is julie
howe
our copy editors are caroline braun emmy
kolzak cindy lightner and jennifer
villaga
ponsdale sue sound designed this episode
and composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners whitney johnson is
the director of visuals and immersive
experiences
david brindley is national geographic's
interim editor-in-chief and i'm your
host peter guinn
thanks for listening and see you all
next time
[Music]
you